I've seen it all.
- The thing is,
Forest is a unique child.
- Everything is gonna be fine.
I want you to have
a good time tonight.
You deserve it.
Okay, um...
- Good luck.
- Thank you.
- Goo-goo ga-ga.
- Hey there, Forest.
I want...
I want milk.
- You want me to get you
your bottle, buddy?
- I want milk!
- Okay.
- This is a ba-ba.
I want mama's milk.
Why can't I have mama's milk?
It's a simple request.
- Well, yeah, well, uh, y...
you can't have Mama's milk
right now, buddy.
Um, how about we play?
- Okay.
I want...
I wanna play with my Legos.
- Okay, yeah.
Okay, buddy, let's, uh,
get your Legos then.
- I wanna...
I wanna put the smallest Lego
in my mouth.
- That's what I'm gonna do.
- No, no, no.
You can't... You can't do that.
- What?
First you tell me
I can't have Mama's milk.
Now I can't have
the smallest Lego in my mouth?
What a night.
This is a bad start.
- Wait, but Forest,
it's dangerous.
- Let me get this straight.
You're in charge of me?
In my house?
- All right, Forest,
it's time for bed.
- I guess then
you gonna sing me a song.
- What?
- Momma always sings me a song
before I go to sleep.
Are you gonna do that for me?
Okay, okay. Yeah. Yes, I will.
♪ Hush, little baby
don't say a word-- ♪
- Keep... keep singing.
♪ Mama's gonna buy you
a mockingbird-- ♪
- Put my name in it.
I like... I like it personal.
♪ Hush, baby Forest Whitaker
don't say a word-- ♪
- Goo-goo ga-ga.
♪ Mama's gonna buy you
a mockingbird-- ♪
- Good babysitter.
♪ And if that mockingbird
don't sing-- ♪
- Have a good cry.
♪ Mama's gonna buy you
a diamond ring. ♪